for years we've all watched celebrities
accepting awards get played off by the
house orchestra when their speech runs
on too long my parents are really
disappointed when I dropped out of
school thank you but I felt like I
really just needed to find myself let me
just go to Howard look my father you
know well then my girlfriend Gina she
called me up she said girl you have got
to get down to Emory down a hotline I
was like Gina number one why are you
calling me up trying to confuse me you
know Spellman's in Atlanta to second of
all you know I'm vacillating there
Turner with the wrap it up box you've
got that same power makers of the home
stenographer comes the wrap it up box
it's like being the director of an
awards show everywhere you go
young man you've been found guilty by a
jury of your peers the crime you've
committed was very serious before I
sentence you I'd like to say a few words
about your arrest record what the hell
though the sign is real simple B it says
wrap it up I don't think that's a good
idea
now you want some too you better wrap it
up
we'll wrap that gavel of these
talk to the boss was telling me with the
wrap it up box things will come to an
end at the perfect time whenever you
want them to journey girl
[Applause]
not even close not even close hold on
hang in there
can you read wrap it that's a wrap
though wrap it up box in stores now
available at all robots